[Musique]
le fait qu'une lauréate soit primée à
Cannes qu'elle reçoive deux prix ne peut
être que stimulant et un encouragement
pour tous les autres étudiants c'est à
dire qu'à partir de maintenant ils
savent que c'est possible qu'avec du
travail de la patience de la passion ils
peuvent y arriver il faut avoir un
objectif il faut avoir un rêve et je le
répète toujours cette lauréate toujours
elle a mis ses pieds à l'escale elle a
dit je veux aller à Cannes elle en a
fait un objectif elle en a fait un rêve
et à force de travailler et à force
d'être bien sûr il y a le côté
artistique et à la créativité qui est en
chacun de nous mais c'est son travail
qui a fait qu'elle est arrivée à cet
objectif
[Musique]
les films sont tous très différents
c'est des univers différents et des
méthodes très différentes et très
diversifiées donc c'est d'autant plus
d'autant plus intéressant parce que
chacun a son regard sa façon de
travailler et ça crée je pense aussi une
émulation donc j'espère que ça va
encourager des des jeunes de se lancer
dans dans l'aventure parce que plus on
fait de films plus on a de chance d'être
dans des grands festivals internationaux
je pense plus le festival plus le cinéma
marocain peut se développer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus
accessible avec des moyens techniques et
tout ça de faire de films comme par
avant d'où le nombre de jeunes cinéastes
marocains et le nombre de films de films
produits mais je dirais l'essentiel
l'essentiel ce sont des 70 jeunes
cinéastes talentueux et
la formation ça leur a permis aussi de
travailler dans des structures et dans
des méthodes plus professionnelles avec
avec des équipes plus professionnelles
[Musique]